(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Bom, vamos partir aqui, então, para a análise
prática de como você vai analisar esse checklist
em cada caso.
Coloquei aqui no site da Frazão Leilões e
antes queria fazer uma observação com vocês.
Repare que aqui, nesse leilão do Santander, só
tem uma data e a informação que os
débitos de condomínio e IPTU serão quitados pelo
banco até a realização do leilão.
Já aqui, que também é do Santander, tem
a observação de que é a alienação fiduciária
e tem duas datas.
Esse aqui, que tem duas datas, ele ainda
está dentro do trâmite da Lei 9.514
,97.
Tem que realizar o primeiro leilão, se ninguém
arrematar, tem que realizar o segundo leilão.
Esse aqui, que só tem uma data, provavelmente
já é uma oportunidade de terceiro leilão, porque
a gente viu que depois do segundo leilão,
o credor fica livre para vender o imóvel
da forma e pelo valor que ele quiser.
Como a gente está falando na maioria dos
casos de bancos, e os bancos são acostumados
a fazer leilão por causa da Lei 9
.514,97, geralmente esses bancos organizam leilões também
nessa oportunidade pós-leilão obrigatório da lei.
Então seria o terceiro leilão com uma data
só, com um preço que o banco definir.
Então fique sempre atento a essa diferençazinha.
Passar aqui para o leilão que eu separei
para analisar de forma completa.
É um leilão do Santander em Taubaté, que
é o interior de São Paulo.
Tem a foto aqui e o leiloeiro coloca
a data do primeiro leilão, lance mínimo, data
do segundo leilão, lance mínimo, as informações, que
é a unidade 42, condomínio residencial, jardins, o
endereço, a cidade, a área construída, que é
de 70 metros, a área privativa de 148
metros e a área total.
Essa área privativa aqui seria a área do
terreno e a área construída é a área
de fato do imóvel.
Número da matrícula e o cartório de imóveis
que está vinculado a essa matrícula, inscrição municipal,
que serve para a gente buscar débitos de
IPTU.
Então vamos aqui no Google, IPTU Taubaté débitos.
Vamos ver o que o site apresenta para
a gente.
Tem aqui no cantinho IPTU, inscrição imobiliária, segundo
avio de IPTU.
Vamos aqui na dívida extrato de débito imobiliário.
Vou jogar o número, pesquisar.
Ele já informa que é um imóvel do
Santander.
Vamos imprimir aqui para ver se vai apresentar
a relação de débito.
Está aqui, nenhum débito foi encontrado e realmente
bate com o endereço que a gente está
analisando, Arnaldo Felipe, 77, casa 42.
E está como propriedade do Banco Santander, que
é realmente o banco que está levando o
imóvel a leilão.
Então vou voltar aqui.
Depois ele continua falando que o edital, as
condições de venda estão como documentos do lote,
anexo.
A gente vai ler com calma.
E fala que a venda é condicionada ao
não exercício do direito de preferência do fiduciante.
A gente já sabe que até a data
do segundo leilão, o devedor tem direito de
preferência para ficar com aquele imóvel.
Mas desde que ele quite a integralidade da
dívida e não só aquele montante inicial que
ele estava devendo no momento da consolidação da
propriedade.
Então até a consolidação da propriedade, o devedor
pode pagar só aquilo que estava em atraso,
aquelas poucas parcelas que estavam em atraso e
que levaram o credor a consolidar a propriedade
em seu nome.
Da consolidação da propriedade até o segundo leilão,
o devedor só pode exercer direito de preferência
se ele quitar a integralidade da dívida.
Fique sempre atento a isso.
Vamos passar aqui então para os documentos do
lote.
Deixa eu fechar aqui o IPT e o
condomínio.
Começar pela matrícula consolidada.
Está aqui a matrícula do imóvel.
Sempre começa com a descrição do imóvel.
Então unidade 42, do condomínio, residencial, jardins.
Acesso pela rua Arnaldo Felipe.
A metragem, está tudo batendo ali com as
informações do leiloeiro.
Área privativa de 148.
170 metros de área privativa destinada à construção.
Então de fato é o que construíram desse
imóvel.
Repare que quando essa matrícula foi constituída em
2008, esse imóvel ainda estava em construção.
Pela foto aqui, a gente analisa que ele
já está todo acabado.
O proprietário, tinha aqui o primeiro proprietário, que
era uma empresa de construção incorporadora.
E no registro 1, já tem ali a
informação de que foi feita uma venda através
de um instrumento particular do dia 22 de
outubro de 2008, que a construtora, qualificada aqui
como proprietária, vendeu ao Éric.
E aqui tem todos os dados do Éric.
Também fala que o valor de venda foi
de R$ 120.500, dos quais um
pouco mais de R$ 37.000 foi
pago com FGTS.
Uma informação importante, consta aqui que a transmitente
acha-se com sua situação fiscal regularizada perante
o INSS e a Receita Federal consoante a
certidão negativa de débitos número tal.
Tem o número da certidão aqui.
Por que essa informação é importante?
Dívida de INSS existe quando o imóvel vai
ser construído.
Quando tem a construção, deve ser recolhido o
valor para o INSS daquela construção, daquela obra
que foi feita.
Essa dívida pode acompanhar o imóvel se ela
não for paga corretamente.
Mas como a gente tem aqui na matrícula
a informação de que foi expedida uma certidão
negativa de débitos, e se foi expedida essa
certidão é porque não existe débito, não existe
ali dívida de INSS, então você não precisa
se preocupar com isso.
Seguindo aqui, Registro 2, alienação fiduciária, que o
Éric, que é o proprietário qualificado no Registro
1, transferiu em caráter fiduciário a propriedade do
imóvel à Caixa Econômica Federal.
A gente já sabe também que quando existe
alienação fiduciária de imóvel, o imóvel deixa de
ser de titularidade do proprietário e passa a
ser de titularidade do credor.
Então é isso que está falando aqui no
Registro 2.
Coloca aqui a taxa de juros, a garantia
no valor de R$ 38.249,00,
o prazo de pagamento de 240 meses, e
quando é que começa a primeira parcela?
Dia 22 de novembro de 2008 e o
valor da primeira parcela?
R$ 512,00.
Seguindo aqui, a verbação número 13 tem a
conclusão da construção.
Então, só voltando aqui, logo no começo a
matrícula informava que estava em construção.
A verbação número 3 informa que acabou a
obra, o imóvel já está construído e agora
tem o condomínio residencial Jardins nesse local.
Cadastro municipal, que é aquele número que a
gente usa para buscar débito de PTU, a
gente já localizou lá que não tem débito.
Cancelamento da propriedade fiduciária.
Foi realizado.
O cancelamento da propriedade fiduciária é registrado sobre
o número 2 dessa matrícula, ficando, em consequência,
consolidada a plena propriedade na pessoa de Eric.
Ou seja, o Eric que tinha aqui essa
alienação fiduciária em aberto com a Caixa Econômica
Federal, pagou tudo, a Caixa liberou a dívida
e aí passa a ser o imóvel novamente
do Eric.
Averbação 6, casamento.
O Eric casou com a Maria.
Registro 7, compra e venda.
O Eric e a Maria venderam ao Paulo
e a Cláudia pelo valor de R$
295 mil esse imóvel, sendo que R$
95 mil foi pago com recurso próprio do
Paulo e da Cláudia.
Registro 8, alienação fiduciária.
O Paulo e a Cláudia fizeram uma alienação
fiduciária com o Banco Santander para uma dívida
no valor de R$ 200 mil.
Está aqui a taxa de juros que eles
fizeram, o vencimento da primeira parcela, que foi
dia 17 de fevereiro de 2017, no valor
de R$ 2.249,10.
E o imóvel foi avaliado em R$
250 mil.
A gente já sabe que um fator importante
do contrato de alienação fiduciária é realmente o
valor de avaliação do imóvel, que esse valor
vai ser utilizado no primeiro leilão.
Obviamente que esse valor passa por uma correção
monetária e vai ser utilizado como lance mínimo
no primeiro leilão ou valor venal calculado lá
pela Prefeitura, o que for maior.
Seguindo a verbação 9, consolidação da propriedade em
nome do Banco Santander.
Consta aqui que pelo requerimento firmado em São
Paulo no dia 6 de novembro de 2020,
instruído com as notificações extrajudiciais feitas aos devedores
fiduciantes Paulo e sua esposa Cláudia e comprovante
do empagamento de TBI, realizado o procedimento disciplinado
no parágrafo 7º do artigo 26 da Lei
nº 9.514, de 97, procede-se a
consolidação da propriedade no nome do Santander.
E a gente já sabe que esse procedimento
aqui que está especificado é realmente notificar para
a Pulgueira Mora, abrir o prazo para pagamento,
se não pagar, consolida a propriedade.
E uma informação também é que o primeiro
leilão deve ser realizado no prazo de 30
dias.
Vamos reparar aqui que essa verbação foi feita
dia 15 de fevereiro de 2021.
Então, teoricamente, respeitando esse prazo de 30 dias,
o primeiro leilão teria que ser realizado até
15 de março de 2021.
Não é o que está acontecendo aqui.
O primeiro leilão está sendo realizado em abril
de 2021.
Os nossos tribunais entendem que não há problema
de respeitar um pouco esse prazo, que isso
não causa prejuízo ao devedor.
Inclusive, é muito difícil que o credor consiga
respeitar esse prazo de 30 dias, que ele
é um prazo muito curto, para encontrar um
leiloeiro, combinar as condições com o leiloeiro e
aí realizar, de fato, o leilão.
Então, nossos tribunais falam que não tem prejuízo
ao devedor realizar com pouco mais de 30
dias.
Então, tudo certo quanto a isso.
O leilão não vai ser anulado quanto a
isso.
Se por acaso você bater com um leilão
que da data da consolidação da propriedade até
a data do leilão passou muito tempo, anos,
aí sim você liga para o leiloeiro e
pergunta o que aconteceu.
Provavelmente existiu uma decisão judicial mandando suspender aquele
leilão até a decisão definitiva do judiciário.
Mas sempre verifique se tiver muito tempo.
Se for um prazo curto de alguns meses,
não tem problema.
Partindo, então, para a análise do edital do
leilão.
Está aqui o edital completo.
Já começa informando a data do primeiro e
do segundo leilão.
O nome da leiloeira, que é uma leiloeira
oficial, escrita na Junta Comercial de São Paulo
e o número.
Então, é só entrar lá no site da
Junta e verificar.
Vai ser um leilão híbrido, realizado de forma
presencial e online.
O credor é o Santander, tem todos os
dados Santander.
Os devedores, o Paulo e a Cláudia, e
também os dados da Cláudia.
A realização do primeiro leilão, dia 1º de
abril de 2021, às 14h30, pelo lance mínimo
igual ao superior.
Aí está aqui, que é ou o valor
da avaliação ou o valor venal estipulado pela
Prefeitura.
O número da matrícula do imóvel.
O cartório está registrado.
E aqui toda a descrição do imóvel, que
bate certinho lá com a descrição da matrícula.
Sempre confira isso.
Cadastro municipal para pesquisar adeptos de IPTU.
A gente já achou.
Venda em caraterá de corpos, que significa que
você está comprando o imóvel por inteiro e
não necessariamente vinculado à metragem daquele imóvel.
Então, caraterá de corpos é o oposto da
venda vinculada à metragem.
Caraterá de corpos é a regra, tanto de
leilão, quanto do mercado imobiliário.
Para imóveis urbanos, seja imóvel residencial, imóvel comercial,
a regra é sempre carater ad corpus.
A gente vê lá mais venda vinculada à
área específica e imóvel rural.
Então, ad corpus é a regra de leilão
e também do mercado tradicional.
Caso não haja licitante, em primeiro leilão, desde
já fica designado o segundo leilão no dia
9 de abril, pelo valor mínimo igual a
R$ 221.001,00, que é o
valor da dívida mais encargos.
Fala aqui que os interessados em participar de
modo presencial devem comparecer à rua tal e
os interessados em participar de modo online devem
se cadastrar, mandar lá a documentação, identidade, CPF,
comprovante de residência, para quem for casado também
os dados do cônjuge e se habilitar com
antecedência de uma hora.
A gente sabe que você precisa se habilitar
para oferecer lances específicos em leilão.
Se habilitar não tem nenhum prejuízo, você pode
se habilitar em quantos leilões você quiser e
depois não oferecer lance em nenhum desses leilões.
O que você não pode fazer é oferecer
lance e depois desistir do leilão sob possibilidade
de ser punido.
Coloca aqui o site do leiloeiro.
Fala que o pagamento desse leilão vai acontecer
em 24 horas, bem como o valor da
comissão do leiloeiro, de 5%.
Em leilões prejudicial, essa não é a regra.
Cada edital pode estipular de uma forma, fique
sempre de olho nisso.
Fala dos direitos de preferência do devedor, que
a gente já falou aqui antes de começar
a analisar.
Fala da desistência do arrematante, que ele vai
ser multado em 20% do valor da
arrematação, além de pagar os 5% da
comissão do leiloeiro.
Então, muita atenção.
Só dê lance no que realmente você quer.
Se não, tem a chance de depois você
desistir e ser multado.
No primeiro leilão, o valor do lance mínimo
será nos termos do parágrafo 1º do artigo
27 da Lei nº 9.514,97.
Valor da avaliação ou valor venal, o que
for maior.
E no segundo leilão, muita atenção aqui, será
aceito o maior lance oferecido desde que igual
ou superior ao valor da dívida, das despesas,
dos prêmios de seguro, dos encargos legais, dos
tributos e das contribuições condominiais.
Então, para esse leilão específico aqui, condomínio IPTU
vai ser pago até a data do leilão.
Você não precisaria se preocupar com isso.
A gente já viu que IPTU lá realmente
não tem débito, a gente já fez essa
pesquisa.
Condomínio, se passasse a responsabilidade para o arrematante,
você teria que levantar esses débitos diretamente com
o condomínio.
Nesse caso aqui não precisa, que vai tudo
quitado.
Correrão por conta do arrematante todas as despesas
e procedimentos relativos à arrematação do imóvel, tal
como taxa, alvará, certidão.
Isso aqui é o registro do imóvel.
Você tem que saber quanto vai te custar
esse registro do imóvel, por isso que lá
no módulo 1 tem as tabelas dos tribunais
para você verificar esse registro.
Depois vem o texto da evicção, a gente
já sabe que evicção tem uma aula própria
disso.
Se você não lembra bem, volte lá na
aula e reveja e os prazos para que
a venda aconteça.
Então, do ponto de vista da matrícula, tudo
certo.
Tem a consolidação, tem a informação que o
devedor foi notificado para aporgar a mora.
No edital do leilão tem também essas informações,
tem as datas do leilão.
A última verificação que a gente faz sempre
é de processo judicial que possa existir, porque
é a nossa segurança, mesmo que não seja
informado no edital do leilão ou na matrícula
do imóvel.
Lembrando que se for informado no edital do
leilão, na matrícula, ou alguma outra forma de
divulgação pelo leiloeiro de que existe processo, existe
a possibilidade de respringir os limites da evicção
de direitos por falar que o arrematante assumiu
o risco.
Você vai fazer essa pesquisa independente dessa informação,
porque é uma segurança sua de qual é
a característica daquele devedor, se ele está deixando
o barco seguir ou se ele está reclamando
de algo.
Então faça sempre essa pesquisa.
A gente está falando aqui de um imóvel
do Santander, então como não é Caixa Econômica,
não é Justiça Federal, é Justiça Estadual e
é em São Paulo, talvez até o interior
de São Paulo, então TJ de São Paulo,
para realizar essa busca.
Processos, consulta processual, consulta processual de novo, consulta
processual de primeiro grau, vou copiar aqui o
nome do devedor que está no edital, para
facilitar, Paulo Francisco Fernandes.
Então vou mudar aqui, o nome da parte,
copiei, não sou um robô, consultar.
Não existe nenhum processo do Paulo contra ninguém,
nem ninguém cobrando o Paulo também de nada.
Só por garantia, eu vou botar o nome
da esposa do Cláudio aqui também.
Também não existe processo, então eles não estão
alegando nada, a documentação está ok, o que
você precisaria fazer, se fosse o caso do
condomínio sobrar para você, ligar lá para o
condomínio e saber se tem débito, para que
você tenha plena noção se vai sobrar algo
para você ou não.
Use esse mesmo contato para levantar informações do
ocupante, quem é que está morando lá?
É o devedor?
Ok.
É um locatário com contrato com o devedor?
Se não for, sinal de alerta, porque isso
aí pode gerar uma uso campeão, então nosso
objetivo não é participar desse tipo de leilão
que pode ter algum problema.
Então, muito sinal de alerta, está aqui no
Google, telefone desse condomínio, liga, pergunta quem está
ocupando, pergunta qual é o estado de conservação,
se fosse o caso, débito de condomínio, tira
todas as suas dúvidas e faça uma arrematação
tranquila.
Siga sempre o checklist, a gente ainda vai
analisar mais um outro imóvel que foi a
leilão mais prejudicial para consolidar todas essas informações.